I don't value people's judgement I think
people struggle with judgment if you're
judging me you're weak not me
you got your prospective happy don't you
want to be happy
[Music]
[Applause]
my questions around you spike that
wanting admiration which i think is a
really courageous thing to admit to
being you're crushing it you also talk
about altruism and helpful nannies
when you see the line between the two is
like read all about helping a charity
nonprofit and I'm terrified at the idea
of putting myself in the spotlight so we
see the line between two you know I
think I think the thing that I talked
about very quickly up there about I want
health for you and then I want
self-awareness I think the line is
everybody here's got a different line
there you know I don't think anybody
here should live on anybody else's line
I think the key is to try to figure
yourself out you know I didn't realize
you know that reason that I was a class
clown it was because I wanted attention
because you know I was getting it at
home I think the line goes in a lot of
places I think the truth matters the
most there's a lot of people that play a
non-profit when I sent on nonprofit
boards and I realized that people join
that board to get access to me for
business purposes that was a real
eye-opener to me
and so I think everybody has their own
line but I think it's important to
expose what you're selfish about because
so many people try to position
themselves as selfless at all causes and
that's just not human I think admiration
doesn't feel very courageous to me
because the way I process it is I'm
desperate to bring you more value than
you bring to me so that I have leverage
of your admiration which by virtue feels
like you're just wanting to be a good
person for the sake of something that's
in you so I just think that you have to
draw the line where you draw the line
and listen if you do if you're naturally
private there's that super fine my
question is why though and I think one
of the biggest reasons people are
naturally private is because they're
hiding things they want two things they
want stuff but they also want to keep
certain things secrets and so I just
think you have to be thoughtful if
you're not honest with yourself you're
fundamentally finished and I think
that's what I'm pushing on
I got urgent
ha
LinkedIn LinkedIn is if you're in b2b or
you're trying to get the business people
I'm blown away I actually tweeted this
the other day I'm just stunned how much
of a Content platform link that has
become because for a lot of us here
LinkedIn was a utility for recruiting
and just reaching out to people using
LinkedIn is not spamming people on
LinkedIn messaging using LinkedIn is
using LinkedIn the way you use Facebook
or Twitter putting out meaningful
content it finds itself to the right
people in that world
[Music]
I think being happy and that's where I
think all these words passion for being
happy is imperative because it takes so
many hours it takes so many hours to
beat the other people to get yours kind
of thing or just to take advantage of
the abundance if you don't I'm just I
just think most an enormous amount of
people do it for the money which has
nothing to do with happiness and so I
think purpose passion process like I get
such a high out of the tough part like I
like the bad stuff
I like the setbacks I'm actually
unbelievably addicted to the
negativities of running a business the
hard parts
when you love the process you've
achieved your goal you have understand
the money for me is a collateral to
loving the process even the way you ask
that question you're looking for more
money than I'm looking for I'm just and
by the way that doesn't mean I'm right
or you're like just even the way you ask
the question I've already won by putting
myself in the process all the other part
is secondary got it so you're not gonna
be in it for the process I mean that
which is okay it really is okay the key
is trying to figure out why you want the
other stuff it's okay to want money why
a lot of people love the idea of money
so they don't have to work that usually
doesn't work out
right next question let's keep the
questions to one holy please
- door
they're making delivery by national
services like cause everything for all
males at this
it's also sometimes miniature and
with love be gentle
how do you replicate around with me a
whole life for pretty much two years
because you have no choice again and
then we the world's going so fast
America might be a few years the world
will be there for you when you're done
doing your military service just because
you don't want to do it or because
you're excited to do the stuff that you
want to be doing but you're mandatory
you were born in Singapore bro you're
going to the [ __ ] military yeah you
know like that's just the way it is and
that's that and so there's pros and cons
to everything you could've been born in
a digis country like like you know like
there's a lot worse places to win the
lottery than Singapore you know you like
Israel and other place in the world
you're gonna have to pay your services
but this whole thought that I'm gonna
miss out on my time is ludicrous if
you're good enough if you're good enough
the years that you were in the military
aren't gonna be the reason you do loss
don't use it as an excuse bro welcome
yes
not just get closer to the mic
I'm fine with it but if they wanted not
let you that's you know I'm in their
house so I have to be respectful
I remember I remember
[Music]
again
yeah
it's pumpkin
moving on
yamaneika critters will pick spots of a
mercedes-benz and many
I was telling you those those right when
you come home Davina thank you though
last night you were in Malaysia I was
tracking you on twitter as well but
right when you're photographing so I
focus pictures with Olivia also I just
wanted to make sure that I make your
engine you know thank you very much
we're together I respect that and I
don't
all right I don't spend thousands of
dollars on illegal things under 35 years
old I think not just five four years
five years this happy but in Spanish to
make it successful for a tomorrow
good for you man yeah that was the
question yeah so internship in New York
yeah the biggest problem is I don't know
if you've been reading the news but you
you get the visa
I'm absolutely open to it ready yes
welcome me Gary at vaynermedia your
email and say I got the inverter ship
Wow
you got it not no statements and uh and
requests but my question is
yeah it's looking at me like that make
me sin but my question is wanna be
practical the next 12 to 24 months
where did we do it early the voice of
the spice what do we do to go to only
preparing for the faculty
yeah I would download all of the apps
and I would get involved in all of the
conversations because there's not enough
to do just yet yeah it's just like
iPhone apps you know what else you can
do go read about the first two years of
iPhone apps be very educated on 2007 and
8 iphone apps because what happened they
are is gonna happen on voice look for
pet look for patterns thanks
South Karen how are you I'm good my
name's Justin with that as well with
both of her sorry it's so hard to ask
you a question I mean you give so much
value and some of the questions are us
like guys seriously like [ __ ] up but I
want to ask the room practical question
a little bit operational right so I run
a service business at birth
how do you talk about giving value yes
value value value and something that we
struggle I guess is growing a service
business is this apply management yes
and you should I think in a couple
nuggets here and there across very
rarely around even being anxious around
some client challenges like you know
coming out of this event being like
right dealing with a challenge but my
question is how do you empower your team
to give value versus running money or
loss and obviously in the lifestyle of
business how do you empower client
management teams to make decisions of
value versus just burning budget and
dollars um by continuing the cotton is a
very good question by the way a lot of
communication with them I think the
biggest issue the client service people
make is they make decisions they think
the client needs without listening very
careful to the client every client is a
control of the subjective nature of what
the value is that they bring some like
schmooze some like black and white I
think what you're looking for is empathy
the best client service people have deep
empathy which gives them the ability to
know which way to turn the way I empower
them is by having the conversation
around this with them and then watching
what they do with it
not by caging them into something but
it's a very human thing like as good as
I feel about it
it could change tomorrow because the new
clients been put on that business the
nature of client service business is not
having control which is why I've been
very good at it because I'm very
comfortable and not having control
you're in control of firing your client
service people
that's what you have it's not super
complicated you just need to know what
you signed up for yeah it's good
so
actually wrong yeah bar so I follow you
if that's your August until this is
January I've only got six six months but
now I got one anymore cos I've started
doing actually and my [ __ ] here is you
can see the bar it's a very developing
country God the country so I actually
saw something my own marketing you can
see so so if you are not boring not go
to doctor say America or even in
Singapore if your body at that country
what what did you do some company
because you have chains everywhere so
what would give one more time I want to
make sure I understand the question
it's a so so I'm actually I'm actually
doubling luckily you can see thank you I
understand yeah so if you are not in the
party the Marika I could not eat
Singapore if you in the pub a country or
country how would you start up a company
the same way I would do it in America I
would get a client the first client take
the money and start building from
scratch are you making it are you making
the assumption or positioning that
there's more dollars in the system and
bigger countries actually nobody is
nobody understands it in America either
I'm being serious I actually think it's
more interesting and doing business in
developing markets because to your point
nobody understands what you're alluding
to is that means a lot of people gonna
say no to you people say no everywhere
you know what's good about being in a
developing country where a lot of
customers are saying no you're not
competing with a lot of people it's
easier to build a digital marketing
agency especially for somebody who's
been watching me carefully for six
months in a third world or developing
country than it is in Singapore or
America easier so go show me
I've seen ya go 24/7 how do you maximize
your time every day
by hiring two full-time assistants who
try to make sure I don't do anything
that's logistics oriented or doesn't
take up my time and by number two not
judging myself if I had a bad day that
wasn't as valuable as it could have been
and then also on Fridays and Sundays
reviewing the two weeks ahead every
single minute I'm spending to make it a
little bit better if I have the chance
to cancel something and bring something
in I mean I don't have a lot of bad days
mainly because I made my bed like I
think if you're a CEO or a founder or an
entrepreneur I don't think it's
acceptable to kind of almost acknowledge
bad days nothing you should suppress
feelings like my bad days are handled
with perspective if my family is healthy
and you know losing a big client or
having an issue of my business is not a
bad day it's about perspective you know
the CEO Pepsi Indra canceled my meeting
with her the other day and I probably
won't see her now for six months it was
a meeting I was looking forward to for
three or four months very important I
thought it could really set up
vaynermedia for 2019 it got canceled I
doubt that I will see her the rest of
the year I didn't consider that a bad
day I considered that [ __ ] part of the
game like I hate it I wish it happened
but I think too many people consider
things bad day because the client
service person [ __ ] up side you have
to put things in perspective
hi Mary my name is Shannon Hessian I get
to restoring life though with your
latest book being titled trashing it yes
can you share about time that you were
really trashed like what happened and
how did you overcome it
I don't think I really had that time
happened yet I anticipate it could
happen but I I it's no different I told
the gentleman just now I reserve being
crushed for when my parents died or
something awful happens to my children I
don't I don't have I don't I'm not a
businessman that overextends myself so
that I can go out of business and I'm
not somebody that really cares about
anybody's judgement on me so the answer
is I don't have an answer to your
question yet hopefully when that day
comes I'll be able to deploy perspective
and be grateful for the good things I
did have but i i i i don't operate that
way
how do you psych yourself up to be like
you know so positive every single day
and you know
negative things come you're just like oh
you know have it I don't value other
people's opinion I I really mean this
guys I don't value your opinion
like I just I don't value people's you
know actually I might have to start
changing that I've never thought of this
like cuz I do value the feedback
tremendously I don't value people's
judgement I think people struggle with
judgment if you're judging me
you're weak not me so I don't struggle
with judgment I just don't understand
what people think when something bad
happens like I don't I think people put
themselves into traps emotional and
financially emotionally they allow
judgement to dictate their behavior they
over and then financially you overextend
yourself and then when you lose an
account you're in trouble I mean I can
lose all of vaynermedia business I'm
gonna make almost much money on this
trip for three days then I'll make at
vaynermedia I'm not kidding because I'm
investing it all back I don't live my
life in a way that I'm trapped
financially I also can live my life
without fancy things I think people are
[ __ ] fancy you know why people are
fancy they want to have a facade to
other people if tomorrow I lived in an
apartment in Newark I'd be super [ __ ]
fine with it maybe it would be a
struggle for me because my wife would
struggle with it my kids would struggle
with it but for me for me I'm [ __ ]
cool with it because guess what what
what
you're welcome
hi Gary my name is by recognizing
regardless of that voice the outcome of
what they do isn't gonna be predicated
by the fear and the doubt going into it
meaning all the fear you had when you
first jumped into a pool swimming wasn't
gonna dictate how good at swimming you
were gonna be I mean I mean like it has
no impact your doubt isn't gonna win or
lose like you know how people like I'm
gonna psych myself up for this pitch and
they get really pumped for the pitch and
then they lose the business well it
didn't work in the same way that you
could doubt something in the net then it
went well and you're like oh that what
you know that is a very important
conversation but what you need to
understand is it has no value it's that
it's not right
such as ignoring you
once you start believing it it's not
right and then you do 20 things and
sometimes the doubt was right and
sometimes the doubt was wrong
you start realizing it doesn't matter
what what I struggle with is how people
don't understand after they live some
life like what the results were of their
life you've had this doubt sometimes it
worked out sometimes it didn't it sounds
like your doubt isn't accurate
you do you know that I go into every
business thing thinking I'm gonna win it
guess what it's wrong because I haven't
won every single thing I've done but
that's my default but but I don't let it
affect me do you understand I'm the
opposite of you but in the same way I
know that it has no value so I don't let
it get me too high or too low how are
you living your life based on other
people to not listen to other people
judgment brother it's the poison of our
society my friend when people judge you
that's an indication of them not you
thank you you rock too
[Applause]
Singapore so for me b2b is critical
understood we love LinkedIn yes so how
can we really crush down like that
how much content don't [ __ ] me now
because I want you to win how much
content are you guys putting out that
doesn't have the agenda of being a top
of the funnel legion to people hiring
you correct
we got it you're in the right hook right
hook right hook right hook business
there's a reason I wrote Jab Jab Jab
right hook go reread it slowly it
doesn't have a floor which is why I
don't love it
the reason I don't talk about it as much
is they've created an artificial price I
still think it might be under priced but
the good thing about me through
experience not the young me is I don't
talk about things until I fully fully
understand it fully my here's what's
blowing me away
organically it's one of the most
interesting platforms brother you're not
putting out content for them you're
putting it out for you thank you you're
welcome
hey Gary how are you great I missed all
time I just don't ask you that's a lot
of digital platforms that we can all
leverage yes right is there a technique
to do it every three marketing funnel is
there what away detecting to field of
every marketing funnel probably but I
want to understand you know the
evergreen marketing funnel is called
brand that's the actual evergreen model
what I think you're asking is something
different so I want you to clarify it
because everything that you put on
different platforms might require you to
change that constantly correct something
that might never go out of time for
example say you can market it for like
one to two months
that's what no because the consumers
attention the algorithms the context
culture sometimes a word overnight
becomes offensive almost nobody I've
ever met in life is actually consumer
centric there's only two people that
I've ever met in the last ten years and
what actually mean one I watched one I
met that blew me away and I said oh my
god
there is consumer centric as me Jeff
Bezos and Mark Zuckerberg and guess what
ten years later they've got two of the
biggest [ __ ] companies in the world
and in ten years I'll be the most famous
[ __ ] person on earth you know why
when you are 100 percent focused on the
customer and not what they can do for
you do you know many people here worried
about how many likes they have versus
worrying about replying to the people
that actually gave them a like selfish
you guys are all [ __ ] selfish and I
can smell it from a mile away I can
smell it from a mile away and I will
tell you that you're selfish
not because I want to be mean because I
want you to be happy brother I know your
agenda staying the same but you're
basically telling me [ __ ] the customer
and I want to be lazy and do one
evergreen thing that's what you just
said Tom so you better rethink your
[ __ ] strategy
and thanks so much you're welcome
brother I hear me I'm Patricia
hyperfunction I run a team of 20 staff
and I know that you have actually
preached a lot about entrepreneurship
and at the same time you have a really
big penis yes right so how do you
actually deal with people on your team
especially those who are overly
ambitious all people once by a fire
message and they want to do something
out there one I want them to go do
something on their own
hey vaynermedia can't be a jail you know
if they're inspired I mean people come
to me all the time and go you know Gary
when I first me a lot of people started
vaynermedia and never heard of me which
is on a great accomplishment I want that
to be the case and they'll say you know
now I'm here a year and I've been
listening their stuff and wait a minute
I think I want to leave and do my own
thing and every time I go let's go how
can I help you
that's rare it's happened what you got
busy and usually like if she wants to
start a paper company or he wants to
start a cupcake company like I'm busy
but I'll introduce them to be seized
I'll give them advice I'll try to help
them and then the other thing is I ask
them to be self-aware you know a lot of
times people don't understand the
transition of you know right now
entrepreneurship is cool it's also very
hard and so you know I asked them to
figure out if they actually are an
entrepreneur so you actually bring them
through your own personal experience and
see if they have the right mindset I ask
questions I ask about their childhood I
ask about them you know if they work for
me I've got a good read on them usually
I can have some sort of read and there's
kids I think that are and I think there
are kids that have no shot kids all ages
I've pushed some people to
entrepreneurship and they think I'm
trying to get them to quit which is the
weirdest conversations I have with
employees but I know they'd be happier
being their own boss so I'm empathetic
hey I'm excited about being on media in
Singapore thank you thank you I asked
question last question
I'm a traitor and I just on the last
question what you said about content is
it purely content or because right now I
have my Facebook page
so I put all the content in you oh the
other days I put up a content let's call
to action which is come to my training
too which one which one is do you
recommend Babu but a lot we put a lot
more of the things that are just good
content for them no Jab Jab Jab right
hook give give give ask so the other
thing is that the marketing you said
marketing marketing marketing puts more
spend more money on Facebook and
Instagram so how much percentage you're
talking about on from out of the profit
or how much if I put a lot many well
don't go broke yeah that's what my
question is no where's the money going
what do you what do you mean let me help
you understand I run a 200 million
dollar company and don't make much money
man why are you stay walking because I
love the process
if I don't you love your lives and your
wife and your family and your other
things yes yeah but I also invest in my
business because my business is the
thing that will let me love my wife and
my things forever but it has to be
profitable is it of course so my
question is how much person is little as
little as possible did I mean 1% 2%
that's not the right way to think about
it how much money do you need to take
home to pay for your life that you're so
happy about and let me ask you a
question do you need 4 sports jackets or
3 do you need 11 pairs of pants or seven
do you need to go on three vacations or
two my friend every dollar you put back
into your business gives you the
potential to have that business be
healthier long term most people start
businesses to take the money out to buy
themselves things which is why they
never build long term big businesses
thank you I guess I just literally told
you up here that I was willing to give
up my house on the Upper East Side my
home in the Hamptons and live in an
apartment in Newark life and living your
life is based on many different things
there's people that make one hundred
fifty thousand dollars a year and then
when they make two hundred thousand
they're miserable but they were happy at
150 that's real life
so you're defining your life on an
arbitrary number based on how much money
you made last year or how much you want
to make this year that is not a mapping
to the happiness meanwhile Facebook is
one of the best deals of all time
happening right now so you're not gonna
invest as much as properly needed
because you want to buy stuff by the way
Mazel Tov enjoy you do you but that's
the debate yeah because I love people
saying come out for that confessor but I
just [ __ ] love the facility this is
why Mazel Tov
just don't complain when your business
doesn't grow that much over the next
decade you're not beating your business
you're feeding yourself good but you
better [ __ ] shut up about why am I
not growing you know why you're not
growing you're not feeding it so they
answer your question why do I do it cuz
I love the process more than the other
stuff you love the other stuff more than
the process that's okay I don't think
I'm right that's just who we are so I'll
probably build billion-dollar companies
and you won't doesn't mean I'm right you
might have more vacations and eat more
food and go to more matches and spend
more time with people that's great life
is about choices but you can't have both
and I think when there's a moment in
time that's special like this it's
probably a good idea to take advantage
of it because you can go back to being
comfortable three years later and oh by
the way that comfortable tends to be far
better than it was three years earlier
so just what you said about Facebook
that one that you've gone through the
Google ads and all those thing right so
it's like how you say that you know a
few people a few month ago saying that
Facebook become more expensive this year
take they're saying that it's gonna be
[ __ ] more expensive incoming yet yes
thank you and by the way it's still a
ridiculous deal G because when you buy
something for two dollars and it's six
dollars you think you think it's
expensive but if you realize it's
actually worth $75
thank you everybody thank you guys
[Music]
[Music]